There's a man who is known for the tails.
He has his phone and told your children young and almost full grown ones like
how to Don's a hat.
One Horton hears a who ends the Grinch who stole Christmas,
got a new hot too.
He was a doctor named Zeus,
but not a doctor at all.
Just a man who loved writing for both big and small.
On today's biographics,
we offer the story of Ted Geisel,
the American author.
Okay.
Theodore's excuse guys.
All was born in 1904 two German immigrants.
His father owns a very successful brewery in Springfield,
Massachusetts.
As a Charles,
his favorite pastime was to go to the zoo with his family every single Sunday.
He was so good at drawing animals that his father bought him a sketchbook.
This he added to every weekends and his mom allows him to paint on the walls of
his bedroom.
His animals always looks like character cheers,
and from a young age,
his parents could tell that he had a very whimsical imagination after
prohibition in the 1920 [inaudible] father could no longer run the brewery.
It's actually chose to become the head of the Springfield Zoo in stat ted guys,
all good now go to the zoo and the sketch to the animals as often as he wants it
and to continue to do this for the rest of his life.
Growing up during World War One,
many children in school would make fun of guys or calling their family drunk and
Germans.
This stereotype only intensified during prohibition since their family's
livelihood came from making beer.
There's isolated him from his peers a lot and he spends a lot of time alone and
it was largely an introvert with the close friends he did have.
He would use this good sense of humor to cope with the bad times.
He was accepted to Dartmouth College and he started drawing short comics for
their humor magazine and his senior year guys all became the editor runs.
This was the beginning of a lifelong literary Korea.
One night the dean caught guys all drinking and a Negro bottle of bootleg Jen
and having a party in his dorm,
so he was removed from his position as editor.
He decided to secretly continue contributing to the magazine and went by the
Penn named Dr Seuss.
So use was his mother's maiden name and when he was born,
his parents made it his middle name in German.
It's actually pronounced Zoya switched.
I'm sure some commenter has commented in below before getting to this point in
the video,
but everyone always got it wrong when reading it with an American accent.
So he just decided to let people call him serious even though he did not have a
doctoral degree,
he decided to go by doctor instead of Mr because his father had always hoped
that his love of animals would have taken him to be a vet,
but instead he chose to be an artist and a writer in stat.
After graduating from Dartmouth,
he moved to England's to attend graduate school at the University of Oxford.
He plans to become a professor but and does not believing after just one
semester to move to New York City.
He was writing funny ads and illustrating them with characters and he was able
to publish his first cartoon in the Saturday Evening Post in 1927 in the
beginning,
Ted Geisel fully intended to write jokes for adults,
but there's ad contracts from publishing any comics in the funny papers because
his clients felt that it would be in direct competition.
However,
the contract and never mentions children's books,
which is why he decided to get started in that genre.
He wrote his first children's book and to think I saw it on Mulberry Street bus.
Every publisher rejected him.
The story is about a young boy.
He uses his imagination to and elaborate over the top details about where he
lives,
which is something that guys will always did as a child publishes,
saw this as encouraging children's Alliance.
They thought it would set about example.
At the time,
children's books were only meant to teach kids moral lessons about manners and
obeying their parents.
They were not exactly enjoyable to read and they were very strict rules about
what could not or could be in them.
Guys will continue to draw ads in New York,
but he eventually ran into one of his old friends from Dartmouth.
He just so happened to have gotten a job at a vanguard press.
His friends helps get Mulberry Street published the book only salt and modest
success,
but it was still enough to get his foot in the door of the industry,
the docsis,
you have spokes continue to feature stories where children web getting into some
kind of trouble.
His stories,
they were fun and it's much more than just a thinly veiled lecture now.
He did have to adjust and right to the market though,
and in 1940 doctors you switched over to random house and he published a book
called Horton hatches the egg,
which gives a moral lesson for children about loyalty and keeping promises.
This book became far more successful than any of his previous titles,
but on the brink of America's involvement in World War Two guys will was about
to take a very long break from writing children's stories
for a long time.
Guys will stop sketching pictures of whimsical creatures and began drawing,
hitting her instead.
What he felt that political cartoons were so important that he started working
for a liberal newspaper called PM,
which published his political commentary for years.
The United States refuse to get involved with the war in guys.
We'll strongly believe that the country needed to help the people suffering in
Europe.
He finally got his wish though because the United States entered world war two
in December of 1941 guys will ones into join and serve in the army,
but he was already in his late thirties which was Fante wold.
However,
he enlisted anyway,
and this is often looking over his resume.
The army recruiter made him into one of the propaganda playwrights and xeons and
the title of Captain Guys.
All they moved to Ted Geisel bent,
his wife found in Los Angeles and puts him in charge of the animation units.
This is where they worked on propaganda cartoons for the U s army equals private
Snafu,
which was very popular among the new army recruits.
Dr Seuss wasn't the only famous names have come out of the army.
Playwrights,
though Chuck Jones was the director of looney tunes and he directed the Cottey
and series.
Stan Lee of marvel comics was also one of the playwrights.
Ted guys all wrote and directed several propaganda films,
including ones that were called your job in Germany and do your job in Japan.
At the time,
he was being criticized for being too sympathetic towards the enemy countries.
This off to the war was over in 1945 these movies were agitators into a feature
documentary called designed for death,
which eventually won an academy award in 1947 he took advantage of this public
recognition by publishing another children's book called Maca Ella God's pool,
which was his first book in seven years.
In 1950 Geisel wrote an animated short story called Gerald Mack boing boing,
and it won the Academy Award for best animated film.
After wedding.
These two Oscars.
He did what most people do in Hollywood,
which was write a full length screenplay calls for 5,000 fingers of Dr t in 1953
the movie is a live action musical about a young boy who's piano teacher is an
evil villain on kidnapping children and forcing them to play his giant piano
forever.
In the first draft of the movie,
the entire story played out very much like his books.
He also wrote songs that made the movie fast paced and exciting bars.
Everything went downhill when the Hollywood executives pushed back saying that
the movie needed an adult love and dressed and drugs risen for the benefit of
parents.
Therefore,
they can't.
Half of his songs and Tartar second screen writes up.
The revisions ruins the story,
ends it flops in the box office.
If you watch the movie,
it's easy to spot the very funny and crazy moments there isn't by Dr Seuss mixed
with the traditional Hollywood drama that made the movie drag on forever today,
5,000 fingers.
It's become a cult classic because it's so terrible that it's actually kind of
good.
Ted guys all said that it was the biggest failure of his career,
that he would never trust executives to make another movie again.
Okay.
Off to taking a long break from writing new books.
Ted Guys all learned that children's literacy rates in the United States were
dramatically low,
so he decided that he was going to do something about that.
This is when he wrote the cat in the hat and it was published in 1957 when he
was 53 years old.
He purposefully wrote the book with a very simple 225 word vocabulary to ensure
that nearly every elementary school child was able to read it.
This book exploded in popularity and it truly did help increase children's
literacy rates.
By 1960 it's sold over a million copies and parents were now searching for more
doctor Seuss books that had been published in the past.
One of guys,
those friends gave them the challenge of reducing the vocabulary down to a mere
50 words and he accepted.
This is when he wrote green eggs and ham,
which was equally as successful as the cat in the hat.
He proved that writing doesn't have to be about showing off a big vocabulary.
The important thing is to tell a good story and he was a genius at doing just
that.
Guys will be getting ahead of children's literature at Random House and edited
his own books as well as contributing to the popular Berenstein bears series.
Now the guys who was in charge,
he made the new goal of random houses,
children's book department to make the stories as simple as possible so that
children would understand every word and enjoy reading the book instead of
struggling this way it would improve children's literacy because they would feel
good about the experience and crave reading more books.
A lot of famous authors to be a part of this project including Charlie and the
chocolate factory author,
Roald Dahl and even breakfast at Tiffany's author treatment capacity.
They both tried to pitch manuscripts to Geisel,
but even though they were both amazing writers in their own rights,
their children's books,
they were rejected for not fully understanding the simplicity.
The guys who was looking for guys all started working seven days a week,
writing and illustrating and published at least one new doctor Seuss book every
single year.
The story seems simple,
but he once said that he wrote over a thousand pages before we could narrow the
story down to just 60 over the course of his lifetime,
he authored and coauthored 66 books
throughout his life.
Ted Geisel got to enjoy the success of having a superstar pen name without the
annoying and invasive parts of being a celebrity,
even though his picture was in newspapers across the country and he received
over a thousand fan letters a day.
Very few children actually knew what the real doctors use looked like,
so he could still blend into society without drawing a lot of attention to
himself,
a cocktail parties in New York and Los Angeles.
Ted was worried that people would expect a lot of him,
so he would tell elaborate stories,
but only speak to one or two people before retreating into another room to read,
smoke,
or have a quiet conversation.
Even though it was quiet,
he was always playing jokes.
Whenever an adult asked for his autograph,
he would write a long and elaborate fake name in the book and hand it back to
them.
He was an introvert,
so socializing more amount in general and he was always afraid that his true
self,
Ted Geisel was an incredibly boring person compared to the whimsical persona of
Dr Seuss.
On the contrary,
friends said that they believe that the select few people,
he chose to speak to you.
We're incredibly lucky and everyone thought he was very interesting.
He just didn't believe in himself.
You would think that for a man who raped children's mercy would have loved being
around kids,
but the truth is that he often felt uncomfortable around children and said that
that just like socializing with adults,
I'm a great while others can be real jacks and he could only handle it for short
periods of time,
but he had to learn to cope,
especially when stories like the cat in the hat became popular and his agents
encouraged him to go on a book top.
Once I'm at a shopping mall,
he slipped away from the crowd of children and started playing pranks on mall
employees by altering the displays.
His agents actually caught him changing the prices of designer shoes to make
them less expensive.
Ted did not want to disappoint the kids though because he knew that when
children imagine Dr [inaudible],
they expected to see someone now to Coupeville.
This he was just a normal guy after a few awkward speeches,
elementary school,
so he decided to stop being himself and acts like Dr Seuss.
He started speaking and sing song the rhymes that he wrote ahead of time and
thought of clever answers to frequently asked questions.
After we started essentially playing a character,
he felt far more comfortable,
even though Dr Seuss wrote children's stories that we're loved around the world,
his personal life was far more complicated.
The story of the woman he fell in love with became one of the main scandals of
his life.
That's in order to the whole story,
we need to go all the way back in time to his college years.
While he was a students at Oxford.
Ted Geisel met a fellow American English major named Helen Palmer.
She was five years older than he was and almost ready to graduate with a
master's degree.
She's not behind Ted in class and when she saw his sketches of animals,
she encouraged him to become an artist instead of a professor.
He dropped out after spending just one semester in Oxford,
but how then went onto graduate.
They got married soon after and moved to New York City together.
She would eventually go on to publish several children's books of her own for
the majority of their marriage and Ted had a very happy relationship and so they
were very supportive of one another's works.
As a young girl,
Helen Sylvania of having polio because of her poor health,
she was not able to have children of our own.
However,
they enjoy the freedom of not having children.
He and Helen traveled to 30 different countries together.
They're in zones or purchase their dream home in San Diego,
California,
Rinse.
They even had a watch tower on top of a mountain.
Helen would edit his work,
giving feedback and we'll say taking care of the household well tend to act in
his office.
For a long time,
that marriage,
it was pretty perfect in 1954 just a year off to his Hollywood movie flops.
Helen was diagnosed with [inaudible] boss and drink,
which is an incredibly painful condition where the body's immune system attacks
is there nuts.
She became completely paralyzed and was placed inside of an iron lung.
If she were to leave this huge metal container,
Helen wouldn't have been able to breathe on her own for a while and they thought
that she might die.
Dead guys will stopped writing and illustrating,
completely giving up everything in his life to be by his side.
Even today,
there is still no cure for [inaudible] Barre Syndrome.
How long has to go through intensive therapy to learn to walk and talk again,
but she continued to be very sick without much recovery time in between to make
it not as worse.
She was eventually diagnosed with terminal cancer like anyone who's feeling ill,
Helen was no longer acting like our usual self.
They started sleeping in separate bedrooms in that relationship became more of a
friendship.
Ted when zones,
I have a secret affair with a married woman named Audrey demand who was
neighbors and friends with the couple,
even though he had fallen in love with someone else,
he never left his wife,
but when Helen was 69 years old,
she found out about the affair and she couldn't handle the possibility that he
may leave her.
She felt that she was 40 olds and Dell's to start her life over and tried to
move on with someone else.
In 1967 she killed herself leaving a suicide notes that was just as lyrical as
their children's books.
Helen died of a drug overdose and tad was completely beside himself with guilt
and grief.
He blames himself a death and sad.
I didn't know whether to kill myself,
burn the house down or just go away and get lost.
Audrey stone demand divorced her husbands and as they got married that following
year,
Audrey was 18 years younger than Geisel.
Then she had two daughters who are nine and 14 at that time.
She sent them to boarding school because she knew that they were unhappy about
the divorce.
The entire community judged Audrey and Ted harshly and as they were shunned by
many of their friends and neighbors because they blamed them for Helen's death,
Audrey and Ted,
they stayed together until his death and he credited her with helping him find
his love for writing again and having a chance at a second life for the first
time he got to experience being a stepfather and to grandfather.
He wrote sometimes when I see my granddaughters make small discoveries of their
own,
I wish I were a child
in 1984 Ted guys,
they'll won the Pulitzer Prize in children's literature and his stories were
translated into 30 languages.
Doctors use is now considered to be a classic author who is towards to each new
generation and his books continue to be reprinted.
Today.
Theodor Geisel was diagnosed with mouth cancer from beers of smoking and he died
in 1991 in the age of 87 three weeks before his death.
He asked for a bed to be moved into his office so that he could be surrounded by
the sketches and sculptures of his characters and have a view of the mountains
from his picture window when he was alive.
Ted guys all did not want any merchandise or movies to be made from his books.
However,
after he died,
his wife Audrey became in charge of this use brands.
She chose to allow licensing to make toys,
games and Hollywood films so long as she was there to oversee the creative
direction and make sure that it would have been up to ted standards.
Some people have criticized,
I've saying that it's exploitation,
but she believes that in today's ever changing world of children's media,
the Dr Seuss stories may have not lasted as long as they have if they didn't get
a modern makeover.
Audrey,
she was right and how decisions have helped keep his legacy alive.
Yeah.
Pads on the 2018 Forbes list of richest dead celebrities.
His book sold 4.8 million copies and and $16 million in 2017 alone because the
state is currently worth around $75 million.
She gives her a huge portion of the proceeds from our husbands royalties to the
doctors use foundation,
which is a nonprofit organization that donates money to various causes.
So all of the money from these new doctors use movie remakes of actually going
to pay for college scholarships,
libraries,
school art programs,
and cancer research.
Surely had Geisel would be happy to know that even years after his death,
his stories are still making a difference with children everywhere.
So I really hope you found that video.
Interesting.
If you did,
please do give us a thumbs up below and don't forget to subscribe.
Also,
I've got another channel.
It's called top tens.
We've got top 10 lists.
We look at all sorts of different fun facts and things like that.
It's a daily show,
so you can go check that out and subscribe if you want to,
you'll find a link on the screen now as well as below.
And as always,
thank you for watching.
Okay.